- Can you do what I do?
- I can do what you do.
♪♪♪
- Oh, shit.
- Oh, yeah, son!
- That is what I'm talking about.
Hell yeah.
♪♪♪
Hello, and welcome to "Underrated."
This is gonna be a good
one. I am Adam Lefkoe.
Gotta give a shout-out to
our sponsor, State Farm,
with their surprisingly great rates.
Today's guest: Keenan Allen,
who surprises defenses every damn week.
And he's also surprised
by his Madden rating,
and I'm not here to stand for it.
This is a biggie.
Keenan's had his run-ins
with Madden in the past.
Jake, get Madden on the phone.
- [Jake:] Calling Madden Ratings Adjuster.
- Clint, old buddy, old pal.
I have a big one.
Keenan Allen.
- Yeah, I love Keenan Allen.
What has he got on his mind?
He's a huge Madden guy,
and you know I love hearing from Keenan.
- You've seen his videos
in the past though, right?
- Oh, absolutely.
- And I just wanna start
this video off by saying
I will not be playing
Madden 20, all right?
No. 1, my overall is at 89.
- Well, I wanna do my part.
I wanna mend this relationship.
Jake, get Keenan Allen on the line.
- [Jake:] Calling Keenan Allen.
♪♪♪
- There he is, the man already stretching.
Those are All-Pro legs right there, sir.
Keenan Allen, how you feelin', bro?
- Not bad, not bad, feelin' good.
- The consensus around the league is
that you were one of the
most disrespected players
from last year, but I
think you're special.
And I wish that more people
saw it like I see it.
- I do too.
- Well, I've got your
ratings from this year.
Would you like to see them?
- Yeah, man. Let's get into that.
- All right, so here is what we got.
I'm looking at 90s across the board
for almost all of your
core receiver skills.
You bumped them up
recently, short and medium,
but deep route running,
cuz I've seen this dude catch some bombs.
How do I improve that?
- So what you're looking
at for deep route running
is routes of 40 yards or more.
Specifically double moves are in there.
We're gonna look at his efficiency
of cut and change of
direction in his double moves,
how well he keeps his speed,
some of his shake and shiftiness
in some of those double moves.
And then, you know, deep over routes,
deep crossing routes, verticals,
a lot of those deeper routes you see
run in the NFL these days.
- Other one, change of direction.
I think this man is quick.
How could I improve change
of direction for Keenan?
- Ooh, that's a good one.
So that's a new rating
coming in Madden 21.
What we're looking for is efficiency
in making drastic direction changes.
How well can you keep your speed?
And, you know, looking for
false steps, footwork, things like that.
Athleticism.
- OK, I might have to call
a friend for that one.
This is a long time coming, Clint.
Keenan, I think we can fix this.
- Man, I've been playing the
game since I was six years old.
Just a little bit of
respect is all I ask for.
- I'm gonna get the footage,
and I'm gonna bring it back.
This will be big.
- All right, talk to you.
- All right, so, Keenan, I am feeling like
there's an opportunity here
to up your deep route running.
Let's show Madden how crisp you are
and how quickly you
can separate from a DB.
- I like what you gettin'
at right here. I like that.
Cuz my speed, it's not
great, but it's not-
- Ain't that bad, but you ain't that fast.
- Casey Hayward!
- I ain't that fast, but I'm legit though.
- Can you do what I do?
- I can do what you do.
- Like this, all this?
- I got all of that.
- Well, backpedaling is also
about how well you change direction.
And since Casey's change
of direction is in the 90s,
let's put you up against him
in a classic camp drill
from back in the day.
- All right, let's do it.
- All right, so what we're gonna do is
Casey is gonna try and
shake you out of your shoes.
Now you've got to mirror him.
The longer you stay with him,
the better your case for a ratings boost.
♪♪♪
- Oh, shit.
- Oh, yeah! Yes, sir!
- How did I look?
- How'd you look?
I'm more interested in how you felt.
- I felt good.
- He looked good.
I was trying to get him off his game
cuz I need his points to go up.
- Casey, I'm letting you know right now.
If I find out that you're
letting him keep up-
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't let nobody win nothing.
So if he's able to follow where I'm goin',
his points should go
up, cuz I'm going hard.
- OK, but I'm gonna need one more of these
to take back to Madden.
- OK.
♪♪♪
- Ah, he doin' that right!
- That is what I'm talkin' about!
Hell yeah!
- He was on form.
- Casey, man, really
appreciate you coming out,
help your teammate today. Thank you.
- All right.
- Appreciate it, brother.
- Now, Keenan, we need to
move on to the main event.
Before we get going,
I did talk to the Madden ratings adjuster.
He told me there are a
few routes he's gotta see
before he does a ratings change.
How are we feeling about a skinny post?
- That's easy money.
- All right, how about post corner?
- Out and up?
- Easier money.
- And I'm gonna imagine that a
deep drag is also easy money?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- And since no other
receiver compares to you,
let's show 'em how well you
match up against yourself.
Because if you can run cleaner routes
than your Madden character, it's a wrap.
Which one of these do
you wanna start off with?
- We could do the deep drag one.
- All right.
Deep drag it is, man.
♪♪♪
Hey! Am I finishing?
Do I gotta finish?
That's life, Adam.
- By the way, who is
the quarterback today?
- My brother, Zach Maynard.
Connection.
- Ah, see, it's that family connection.
All right, skinny post.
Looking like it's gotta be about 12 yards.
There it is.
- Did you see that?
- Yeah, I did.
- Come on, man.
- [Lefkoe:] So the last
one that I have here, man,
is the out and up.
♪♪♪
That was perfect, man.
- Hey, man, it's what I do.
Flawless.
Ain't no DBs out here.
- So, Keenan, I'm gonna take those gems
that you just put on tape.
I'm gonna package them up perfectly.
I'm gonna ship 'em off
to my people at Madden.
And just in case they're still trippin',
I'm gonna get you on the phone.
You can let 'em have it,
and we can really talk
some sense into them.
OK?
- Yeah, man. We gotta talk to
'em just a little bit more,
and I think we been
showing 'em on the field.
We been showing 'em,
and they not, they not,
it's not converting to 'em real well
how it's supposed to be.
So maybe they need a
little word of advice.
- All right.
Keenan, you are the man.
I appreciate you, and I
will be talking to you soon.
- Thank you, man. Appreciate it.
- Clint, Keenan went out there.
He gave it to you.
Your initial reaction of seeing the video?
- Hey, great video once again, Lefkoe.
You know, Keenan has
been a guy that always
calls us out to his camps.
We've always had a very close eye on him.
So, much more of the same,
you know? Very fluid athlete.
- Let's get Keenan on the call.
Keenan, with the beard!
- What's up, bro? What's it do?
- Clint, let's talk about
these particular ratings.
In terms of the deep-ball route running,
we went on that because Keenan's
already high in short and medium.
- He is a top-10 wide
receiver in Madden already.
So, saw a lot of the
things that we already knew
in that portion of the tape.
- Change of direction.
The guy he went up against, Casey Hayward,
one of the best in the game.
What are we doing there?
Keenan, you are going to get
bumped up from an 88 to an 89.
- You mean to tell me I spent two hours
to get one attribute?
- You're the seventh-best
receiver in the game.
- It's a mind thing, you
know what I'm saying?
When I see the attributes,
based on other guys' attributes,
that I know I have better attributes,
it's just a little mind-boggling.
- This is deep in Keenan's heart.
- Absolutely.
This is so real. I can't make it up.
- Clint, so I'm gonna ask
you one quick question.
Is Keenan Allen underrated?
- Just, just a little bit.
He's underrated just a little bit,
but we got him pretty
close. Got him pretty close.
- Just a little bit?
- So really what he's
saying is, "I love you,
but you got me fucked up,
and we're here to keep an eye on it."
- Took the words out of my mouth, bro.
- I appreciate the passion very much.
And the best thing about Madden is
we update our ratings every single week.
So you put it on film,
we're gonna see it.
- That is true.
- You're gonna go up.
- I'm not worried. I
know it's gonna go up.
I go up every time.
I'm not worried about that.
- The passion that Keenan
has, it is surprisingly great.
Just like the rates at State Farm.
Thank you for watching another
episode of "Underrated."
I'm gonna be honest,
I feel bad for Keenan.
I just wanna go and hug him.
We're gonna get these ratings better.
I promise, Keenan. I'm sorry!
♪♪♪